vom spitzenmanager auf die anklagebank
fünf jahre nach der aufdeckung des
diesel skandals hat da mittwoch die
strafrechtliche aufarbeitung begonnen ab
heute muss sich ex audi chef rupert
stadler vor dem oberlandesgericht in
münchen verantworten
neben stadler sind zwei weitere
ingenieure sowie ex porsche
vorstandsmitglied wolfgang hatz
angeklagt es geht unter anderem um
gewerbsmäßigen betrug in über 400.000
einzelfällen gesamtschaden 3,1
milliarden euro
also allen wird vorgeworfen betrug in
mittelbarer täterschaft weil es die
manipulierte fahrzeuge verkauft haben
die kunden darüber getäuscht haben und
dadurch ein schaden entstanden ist
dann wird in allen strafbare werbung
vorgeworfen und mittelbarer
falschbeurkundung weil man zulassungen
beantragt hat einen bestimmten typ also
typ zulassungen die
wo man auch dass die entsprechenden
ämter darüber getäuscht hat über die
abschalten richtungen
das besondere an dem verfahren ist dass
wir es zunächst einmal mit einem sehr
technischen verfahren zu tun haben
werden die strafkammer wird im einzelnen
klären müssen ob tatsächlich die
abgaswerte dieser fahrzeuge nicht der
norm entsprach ob eine software
verwendet wurde um das zu manipulieren
der gewerbsmäßige betrug genauso auch
wie der gewerbsmäßigen betrug durch
unterlassen wird mit freiheitsstrafe von
sechs monaten bis zu zehn jahren
geahndet der prozess findet wenn corona
unter erschwerten bedingungen in der jva
münchen-stadelheim statt
stadler weist bisher alle vorwürfe
zurück der prozess soll zwei jahre
dauern
das urteil wird ende 2022 erwartet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei der schau dich jedes nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren